So I'm just going to show how I added
the polyline to the map with all my
different ice rinks.
So to draw the polyline, I set up
the latitudes and longitudes for
all the different ice rinks, Renton,
Kirkland, Everett, Lynnwood, etc.
And this time I'm just setting
them as LatLng objects.
Earlier they were marker options,
but now they're just latitudes and
longitudes.
I set up my camera position to be
exactly as I did in the earlier sample.
Now in my onMapReady, I just move
the camera to my camera position,
which is Seattle.
And then to draw the polyline
I just call map.Polyline.
It's a new Polyline object,
geodesic true,
and then I just add all
of the latitudes and
longitudes that I had created earlier,
Renton, Kirkland, Everett, Lynnwood.
Notice that I begin at Renton and
I also add Renton at the end.
And then this just closes the shape.
Because what will happen when you draw a
polyline is it will draw from Renton to
Kirkland, from Kirkland to Everett,
from Everett to Lynnwood, etc.
So, if I want to close the shape,
I just want to go back to
the initial one at the end.
And then I will get all my rinks drawn
into a polygon like shape by adding
a polyline.
And this is what it will look like.
Here you can see on my tablet I
have the same map of Seattle, and
I have all the endpoints
of the different rinks.
My home rink of Renton that I showed
earlier on is the beginning and
ending point, and then the polylines
get drawn from Renton to other rinks.
So for example,
this is the rink in Kingsgate.
You can see,
Kingsgate highlighted there.
Or I can go all the way
the rink in Everett, etc.
So, these are the polylines that I've
drawn from me connecting the rinks.
And because I just joined the last rink
at ShoWare back to Renton in my code
the shape gets completed.
And as you can see here,
my second last one was ShoWare.
I then added Renton and
the shape got completed.
So my polyline actually
became a polygon.
You can actually also
do a map.addPolygon and
specify the endpoints and
it will auto close it for you.